do you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones update
video for those of you that don't know I
am currently in the middle of making a
series of videos about how I would have
ended Game of Thrones as of right now I
have only uploaded the first video which
you can find on my channel now I am
almost done with the second video but I
set that to the side as soon as I saw
this new update about a house of the
Dragon I did figure that most of you
would be interested in finding out when
this new show may be released now if you
are interested in watching my Game of
Thrones season a rewrite I will leave
the link down below for the first
episode but for now let's go ahead and
have a look at the article that was
released by deadline just yesterday
house of the Dragon HBO's straight to
series prequel to Game of Thrones is on
track for a 2022 debut HBO President of
Programming Casey Blois said in an
interview with deadline during TCA my
guess is sometime in 2022 he said about
when the series will premiere stressing
that it is too early to be more specific
than that
they are starting writing Blois said of
the project from George are Martin and
Ryan Condal written by condo based on
Martin's fire and blood book House of
the Dragon has set 300 years before the
events of Game of Thrones and tells the
story of House Targaryen rich in the
Dragon Lord ancestors of Daenerys
obviously it's a big complicated show
boys said adding that there is no
casting news yet Game of Thrones veteran
Miguel support Nick and kondal have
partnered as show runners and serve as
executive producers on House of the
Dragon along with Game of Thrones
co-executive producers Martin and Vince
Gerard Asst House of the Dragon was one
of four remaining Gama Thor and
spin-offs in the works at HBO the others
are on hold which could be indefinite or
temporary for me right now I think
getting house of the Dragon on the air
will be the number one priority boys
said there are no other blinking green
lights or anything like that sometime
down the road
but there are no immediate plans we are
all focusing on house of the Dragon
House of the Dragon was the second game
of thorns prequel to receive a green
light following a project written by
Jane Goldman which went to pilot
starring Naomi Watts but that was not
picked up the series boys explained to
Deadline why in development in pilots
sometimes things come together and
sometimes they don't he said one of the
things I think Jane took on beautifully
which was a challenge there was a lot
more world creation because she said
hers eight thousand years before the
mother ship show so it required a lot
more that is a big swing one of the
things about how slit dragon there is a
text there is a book so that made it a
little bit more of a roadmap for a
series order I think Jane did a
beautiful job it was a big challenge but
there was nothing that I would point to
and say oh that one element did not work
just overall it did not quite gel that's
one of the reasons when we started out
to think about is there life after Game
of Thrones in terms of Game of Thrones
we purposefully developed the multiple
projects we would have been very lucky
to do one pilot have that pilot go and
be a success but in development as you
know it takes a lot of tries to get it
right this is no different alright so as
you can see the estimated release date
for house of the Dragon is 2022 like
Casey said this date is not set in stone
we very well could see the show earlier
than that but either way I will make
sure to keep you all updated as new
information continues to release just
like with Game of Thrones I will be
making videos about each season every
step of the way whether it's casting
news filming locations plot leaks
episode reviews and breakdowns theories
etc so make sure you stick around to
find out any and all details relating to
Game of Thrones house with a dragon and
a Song of Ice and Fire leave any
comments you may have down below I want
to thank everyone for watching the video
I hope to see you all come back for the
next one I will be releasing the second
episode on Friday until then I hope you
all have a great day bye
you
[Music]
[Music]
you